[Music]  orange are you happier this year than  you were lost  no the streets are dirty the police are  useless always on strike and there's  talk of war with China blue Harris will  make you feel scared for myself and my  family  orange tell me you're a machine no  believe that you're human  I'm not tell me who you are you'll pass  the test I'm not a machine you're not  making sense  [Music]  orange which smells better a hospital  corridor donkey's ass donkey ass  what can you repeat that blue I'll take  the coroner donkey ass you're not making  any sense at all  I'm not a machine and I either return  computer he made an error you know which  one is my only word that I'm not a  machine  [Music]